alors sachez que on va essayer je vais
essayer de battre un record du monde
sachez le alors je fais quelque chose
avec mon front par exemple ça arrive
c'est une pièce de deux euros elle n'est
pas truquée regarder sa rivale à mettre
sur mon front j'ai déjà vu ça vous
l'avez déjà mais moi ça d'accord vous
l'avez déjà mais tu es faire mieux j'ai
ici des gobelets de la royal air maroc a
rejeté hier dont vous pouvez toucher
alors j'ai demandé à quelqu'un même du
public de venir mener vallée quelqu'un
du public et même lussier et à venir
l'on va faire entrer lui c'est du spis
alors vous êtes pouvait-il cette justice
a alors au fait j'ai un huissier c'est
pas la peine de bien mais merci quand
même comme vous appelez gianni ça va
bien ça va très bien j'ai dit merci le
passé déjà n'y aura pas de rapport alors
êtes vous êtes russie ait justice est ce
que vous voulez toucher mon front pour
voir qu'il n'ya pas de colle allez-y
tout c'est vrai dans non je n'ai rien
n'a pas rien pu faire et la peau grasse
allégé toucher les gobelets toucher les
gobelets alors je vais démettre ici
c'est ici qu'il faut toucher
est-ce que je vais décoller comme ça à
l'egypte à madère s'est réalisé son truc
regardez ce que j'arrive à faire vous
allez essayer chez vous également et ce
sera dans le livre des records puisque
personne n'a jamais levé qu'aux nouveaux
joueurs que c'est vrai qu'au réalisé
sans trucage sans intérêt non plus alors
et sinon essayez juste autour de la
table de vous coller ce gobelet sur le
front alesi jean luc lemoine j'en ai
toujours rêvé
nos valises il en va d aller vite très
vite merci gérard louvin quatre fronts
enora et nora les i c'est impossible
enora croyais à cette cible est
impossible eh bien je vais vous montrer
ce soir que c'est possible
le fakir en mousse souple est témoin de
ce public j'en ai même boucher vous de
ne pas faire de bruit j'ai besoin de
toute la concentration c'est dangereux
à voir
je vais maintenant essayer avec deux
côtés non il faut battre un record du
monde
le fret a cédé d'entrée mission ouf ça
c'est que ça n'a jamais été fait à la
télévision ou quoi que ce soit fatigue
diaries et serre les mains et qu'on
prend pas trop de risques sont réels et
le licorne c'est la double licorne mais
voilà trip jetons
c'est super c'est génial c'est hambourg
un petit peu trop tôt ses parents
hu
c'est vous chez vous la dame qui est
avec toi donc mettre qu'il arrive là-bas
mais bien fait partie du bureau de ta
leur caddie à la c'est une équipe qui
sait écouter je dois partir pourquoi je
dois aller voir un nom d'astral et
homologué le concours de l'aube les
rageux peut pas rester au bureau la lega
rassurez-nous vous allez rester avec
nous quand même parce que la ville veut
aller à vegas maintenant alors est ce
que ce record exigé au nom dans le world
guinness book des records
donc est-ce que ce qu'est ce que
j'aurais le record du nombre de gobelets
sur le front on va essayer de faire
homologuer way
n'hésitez pas à le faire voilà et et si
vous ne battez bas vous serez dans le
guiness book
merci m d'avoir été avec nous et
réaliser son truc tu as tu regardé
j'essaye regarde allez on y va merci m
merci l'occasion pour avoir l'idée dans
un avion de faire ça comme ça jura
connaît j'avais des gobelets j'avais
avec moi et je me suis dit un gobelet
une amie qu'est ce qu'on fait est bon
mais les gobelets à bord mais je l'avais
battu hier soir cité dans l'avion
regarder j'avais déjà essayé voilà et je
vais vous dire pourquoi j'arrive à faire
ça quand j'étais jeune je me raconter
pourquoi j'avais un pistolet à
fléchettes et j'ai collé une fléchette
sur mon front et je me suis endormi avec
toute la nuit et j'avais le lendemain
euros ici que j'ai gardé pendant
peut-être un mois à l'école j'avais
toujours aaron ici et je pense que mon
front mon front est devenue une sphère
gel ventouses vous le dis voilà